[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم واحد من الموضوعات
اللي شغله الناس هذه الايام والحقيقه
شغلهم من سنوات تطور علمي يسمح بزرع شريحه
في مخ الانسان الشريحه ديت وفقا للمتحمسين
اليها وشركات كبيره على راسها المستثمر
الشهير واغنى اغنياء العالم الى مصر بيبشر
ان شركته الجديده اللي بيعملها سوف تكون
قادره على زرع شريحه في المخ حتى تمكن
الاعمى من ان يرى والمشلول ان يتحرك ويجري
وتشفي كل امراض الناس ولم يكن ايلون ماسك
اول من تحدث عن هذه الشريحه اللي هي موضوع
حلقتنا النهارده واللي بتطرح اسئله كتيره
على الفوائد لهذه الشريحه هل هذا مجرد
يعني مرحله اختبارات وتنظير امنها بدات في
الفعل ما هي
المزايا التي يمكن ان يحصل عليها الانسان
وما هي المخاطر التي يمكن ان تترتب على
زرع شريحه في المخ يمكن من خلالها السيطره
على الانسان يمكن اختراقها يمكن يعني
الوصول لبخ الانسان عن طريقها والتحكم في
كل تصرفاته كل هذه الاسئله بنطرحها على
ضيفي النهارده وصديقي العزيز الدكتور احمد
بهاء استاذ الذكاء الصناعي والموجه
الاقليمي لمايكروسوفت مساء الخير اهلا
وسهلا بحضرتك يا فندم انا طبعا طرحت
المقدمه السريعه السؤال في الاول اكيد
المتابعين للتكنولوجيا عارفين واللي مش
متابعين ممكن ننجز لهم في تطور علمي من
عده سنوات
بيسمح بزرع شريحه في المخ الانسان لتحقيق
اغراض معينه تكاد تكون حتى هذه اللحظه هي
التطور الرقمي للاجهزه التعويضيه بدل ما
كان واحد بيحط رجل كده بسيطه علشان يمشي
عليها هم بيحاولوا يشغلوا له رجله ويشغلوا
له ايده يخلوه قادر على الرؤيه والسمع
فعايزين نفهم الاول ما يتحقق على الارض
قبل ما نسال اسئله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اسعد دائما يعني
باستضافه حدائق الكريمه
في الحقيقه انه الموضوع ده له اكثر من شق
خلينا الاول نبص على الشق الخاص بنيورو
لينك او شركه ايلون ماسك وبعدين نتكلم على
باقي الاجزاء او المظله الاعم لهذه الفكره
في الحقيقه انقلهم ماسك بدا يعلن عن
تكنولوجي النيورولينك من حوالي اربع سنوات
وبدا تظهر هذه الشريحه من الشركه بتاعته
اللي هي اسمها نيورولينج باسم لينك وطلع
اكتر من لحد ما وصلنا
لاعلن عنها في ديسمبر الماضي
واطلق عليها اسم تجاري ان 1
معلش احنا هنوقف هنا
ليه مش بيرجع وان لانه في الحقيقه ما زالت
هذه الشريحه لم تحصل على موافقه من
الامريكيه الدوله الامريكيه هيئه الدواء
الامريكيه ولم تحصل حتى حتى هذه اللحظه
على موافقه من هاي الدواء الامريكيه
لتجربتها على الانسان هو بيتوقع ان
التجربه
الموافقه على التجارب على الانسان تصدر في
شهر ابريل او مايو من هذا العام باذن الله
لسه ما عندناش منتج حقيقي ولكنه منطق تم
تجربته على قرود وخنازير ونذهب في المرحله
اللاحقه التي لم نحصل على موافقه عليها
حتى الان على البشر في مايو المقبل او كما
تو هو ممكن ايه طبعا تقصر او تعطيل هذه
المده لكن هم بيعملوا اختباراتهم الخاصه
بهم
ايه هي الشريحه لماذا استطاع الانسان انه
يعمل ده في الحقيقه هذه
الفكره الاول نحاول نبسطها للناس هي عباره
عن
شريحه هذه شريحه 23 ملي في تمانيه يعني
دايما هم بيقولوا ان عامله زي الكوين
الربع دولار 23 مللي مش صغيره وبيحصل لها
زرع تحت الجلد
وبتتوصل
بمايكروفايبرز دقيقه جدا
بالنيوروسيلز اللي موجوده في المخ طبعا
التحدي الرئيسي كان في هذه
الشريحه هو حاجتين الحاجه الاولى هي كيف
يحدث الزراعه لها يصلها بالمخ
بمايكروفايبرز ده معناه انه اي جراح قد لا
تستطيع ان تكون بهذه الدقه عشان كده هذه
الشركه ابتك الروبوت سميته زي ما الشريحه
بقى اسمها التجاري مؤقتا ان وان عملوا
روبوت مخصوص لهذه السيرجيك الاوبريشن او
لهذه العمليه الجراحيه سموه مؤقتا
وبالتالي مبدئيا الجزئين دولت تم حلهم هذه
الشريحه يجب ان تكون متصله برضو بشكل
وايرلس
مع
او معده خارجيه هم بيتكلموا على التليفون
الشخصي للانسان ودي مش اول مره على فكره
يبقى في معده طبيه مزروعه داخل جسم
الانسان تبقى متصله بتليفونه في بيس
كنترولر متصله
نظم ذكاء اصطناعي بتحلل دقات القلب موجوده
يعني ابن عمتي انا شخصيا يعني عنده هذا
فدى حتى احنا
في ناس كثيره عندهم المزروعه تحت الجلد
مزروعه تحت
فبالتالي دي مش حاجه جديده وموجوده عندنا
في عالمنا العربي وبتتم
في الاخر بنستطيع انه
نوصل التليفون بتاعنا بهذه الشريحه
وبتبدا التليفون او كاميرا متصله بالهاتف
سواء كانت كاميره الهاتف او كاميرا اخرى
بايصال ما تراه هذه الكاميرا وتحويلها الى
اشارات عصبيه تصل الى
ماسك وهذه الشبه تترجم هذه الصوره الى
كما يطلقون عليها واحنا كمتخصصين بنقول
كده برضو موزاييك قطعه موزاييك متقطعه
بتبدا هذه الفايبرز تقطع الشيف تقطع
الصوره
وتوصلها كقطع
بالمايكروفايبرز المتصله بخلايا العصبيه
المخ لمركز الرؤيه بحيث انها تبعت الصوره
متقطعه حيث يتم تجميعها في ويرى الانسان
حتى لو كان مولودا اعمى اذن حضرتك بتتكلم
ان التكنولوجيا اللي اعلن عنها ايلون ماسك
هي تم تجريبها على القرده والخنازير وانه
بيستعد لتجريبها ان حصل على الموافقه خلال
شهرين او تلاته وشرحت الفكره من وراها انا
بس عندي سؤالين سؤال بعيد تاكيده ان الهدف
المعلن هو انه يكون البديل المتقدم
للاجهزه التعويضيه ان اللي ما عندوش ذراع
يقدر يحرك دراعه واللي عنده شلل في ذراعه
اللي عنده شلل في رجله رجله تتحرك
الذي لا يسمع
يسمع الذي لا يرى يرى مزبوط مش بس كده اه
ده الهدف القريب جدا ولكن
في هدف اخر على فكره هو اعلنهم السري وهو
قدره العقل البشري في التحكم في الاجهزه
والالات عن بعد وهو عمل ديمه حتى لده ازاي
ان قرد بيستطيع ان يتفاعل مع البشر ويحرك
الماوس ويكتب على الكيبورد من غير ما يلمس
اي حاجه ده هياخدنا لمراحل اكبر من كده
احنا كنا اتكلمنا يمكن في حاله سابقه في
الثوره مسميينها الثوره الصناعيه الخمسه
على ما اتذكر عن الاطار
طائرات العسكريه ذاتيه القياده قبلها من
الممكن انه كيف يمكن مثلا لتيار انه
الصاروخ ياخذ امر الاطلاق بمجرد تفكير
التيار العسكري
اه يعني انا كطيار مش محتاج ان انا اخد
حاجه مانيوال اعمل خطوه مانيوال انا افكر
ان انا عاوز اطلق الصاروخ في اطلق الصاروخ
بالضبط وايه ميزه ده
دايما احنا في علوم الكمبيوتر بنتكلم
وعلوم الهندسه بنتكلم ان اي شيء الكترونيك
هو اسرع الاف المرات من اي شيء ميكانيكا
من اي شيء مانيوال حركه ميكانيكيه بتحصل
فلما يكون الامر ان طبعا في قياسات بتتكلم
مش عارف نص ثانيه والعين بترقص في نص
ثانيه او العقل بيرد في الثانيه فده بيوفر
لنا عدد محدود من الثواني قد تعني
الانتصار في معركه او الهزيمه فيها جراحيه
او في اي حاجه زي كده فلما تبقى اشاره
عصبيه هي نتيجه الاطلاق السبب الاطلاق
السبب الاطلاق او سبب الاكشن العمليه
بتبقى اسرع طبعا في ابلكيشن اخرى لكن هو
مش بس كاجهزه تعويضيه عشان نلخص الفكره
ولكنه كمان اجهزه تعويضيه او كنترول ل ااا
العالم الخارجي التكنولوجي
لتفاعل
العقل البشري من والى مع
التكنولوجيا والروبوتس واجهزه الكمبيوتر
طيب انا قبل ما انتقل للسؤال التاني معنى
كده ان الشريحه دي المفترض ان هي غير ان
هي هتساعد الانسان المريض انه انه يحرك
ايده اذا كان مشلول او يرى اذا كان يعني
كفيف وهكذا انت بتقول حضرتك انه كمان ممكن
يستخدمها للتفاعل يعني مثلا ان انا عاوز
اعمل افتح التليفزيون او ادور العربيه او
ان انا اسحب فلوس من البنك فيبقى انا عندي
حاجه مزروعه في جلده تخليني اعمل ايه
اديني مثال او اثنين طيب بشكل سريع حضرتك
فتحت الموضوع نتكلم بقى بشكل اوسع في
الحقيقه ان كل هذه التقنيات بتعمل تحت
مظله
ثوره جديده في العالم
ستسبق الثوره الصناعيه الخامسه
يعني تبقى اكثر تطورا لا هتحصل قبلها
قبلها لما تحدثنا في الثوره الصناعيه
الخامسه قلنا ان الثوره الصناعيه الخامسه
هو عصر تعايش الانسان مع الروبوت ومع
الاله وانه تسير مظاهرات ومطالبات في
العالم
ل التقنين زواج الانسان من الاله مثلا
دي مرحله بنسميها البوست هيومانيزم بعد
البشريه ما بعد سياده البشريه وحدها في
العالم حتى يستطيع الانسان ان يعايش
الروبوت والارتفيشن او علوم الذكاء
الاصطناعي التي ستسلح الروبوتس ونتعايش
معها وللاسف للمره الثالثه والرابعه سيحدث
تزاوج بين الانسان والروبوتس يجب ان نحضر
الجسد البشري والانسان البشري انه يكون من
القوه ومن فتنس اللياقه انه يتفاعل مع
الاله ففي ويف دلوقتي او موجه جديده ستحدث
قبل شيوع الثوره الصناعيه الخامسه اللي هي
شيوع ثوره البوست هيزم هي ثوره الترانسيوم
يعني ايه ترانسيوم احنا كلنا نعرف
اللي هو قلنا انه التحول الرقمي تحول لايه
يعني هذا اللفظ دائما نتحدث عنه
التحويل الاعمال
باستخدام التقنيات الجديده
حولنا صناعه النقل باستخدام اوبر سياحه
بالايرامبي اير بي ام بي او اكسبيديا
الاعلام بنتفليكس وهكذا
عصر الترانسيومانيزم بعد ما عملنا
الديجيتال
وحولنا الاعمال من خلال الثوره الصناعيه
الرابعه ثم بدانا نطول في الثوره الصناعيه
الرابعه لما اطلق عليه انا النهارده
اندستري فور بوينت هو تطورات هذه التقنيات
سندخل في عصر
المرحله الوسيطه ما بين الثوره الصناعيه
الرابعه
بتطوراتها والثوره الصناعيه الخامسه يحدث
فيها تحول للجسم البشري حتى يكون
مؤهل للتعايش مع الاله
الترانسيومانيزم ده مفهوم مش جديد تحول
البشري التحول البشري بالظبط
هذا مفهوم
بدانا نتكلم عليه من 2016 و2017 ويمكن من
اول ارهاصاته رجل اسمه نيل هاربسن اتمنى
ان اكون يعني
بقول اسمه مزبوط
مين اللي حرب ده رجل ولد ضريرا
وزرعوا له انتن في
الجمجمه هنا
ويوصلوها بالمخ وحطوا في اخر الانتينا
سينسورز وكاميرا عشان ينقلوا له الرؤيه
اللي هي نفس فكره ايلون ماسك ثم ظهر علم
مهم جدا هو علم السمارت داست او الخوبار
الذكي في نفس الموجه الغبار الذكي ان يتم
تصميم كمبيوتر عباره عن اثنين مللي في
واحد مللي يعني اصغر كمان من الشيب بتاعه
23 مللي
حد يقول لي ايه ده هو هو التكنولوجي وصلت
لهذا الحجم
لهذا الحجم طب احنا هنا بنقول دي حاجه
هتتزرع تحت الجلد وبرضو قد كوين احنا
وصلنا الى ابعد من هذا بكثير لان النهارده
اعلنت بشركه الشركه الاضخم في العالم وكنا
اتكلمنا على شرائح الرقابه ايوه
عملاق صناعه الرقائق في العالم
اعلنت عن ابحاث مشتركه مع الام اي تي عن
وصولها
البيز النظري لي يمكنها من عمل ميكرو شيبس
بتاعها
للقطر بتاعها يعني حجمها قد ايه عشان نقدر
نترجم بالعربي عشان نقدر نترجم ده
الخليه الدم الحمراء الواحده 7000 متر
يعني ما اقدرش اشوفها بالعين لا طبعا
العلمي ده انا بقول لحضرتك هي واحد التشيب
الترانزستور ده الترانزستور ده واحد على
سبعه الاف من خليه الدم الحمراء
عشان انا اقدر اعمل بروسيسور انا محتاج
لكميات ضخمه من هذه الترانزستورز ولكن ان
انا اقدر اصل الى هذا الحجم عشان اوضح
لحضرتك اكتر كوفيد 19 الذي حير العالم بعد
الدراسات بتقول انه بتاعه 100
نانوميتر اذا انا معلش انا اسف حضرتك انت
عشان بس
ما نفقدش الفكره فرصه تفاصيل المهمه جدا
حضرتك بتقولها اللي انا كنت بقول عليه ان
الشريحه فانت حضرتك بتقول للشريحه دي جزء
من مضل اكبر المظله الاكبر دي اسمها
ثوره علميه بتسموها الغبار الذكي او
السمارت داست والغبار الذكي عباره عن صنع
اجهزه كمبيوتر بحجم صغير وهم تمكنوا من
صنع كمبيوتر صغير الحجم لان في تطور تاني
في صنع مكونات الكمبيوتر من اجزاء صغيره
جدا
وتقصد انه هيتم زرع الكمبيوتر ده في
الانسان او تحت جلده بحيث ان يقوم بوظائف
مختلفه لا هو مش مش مجرد في مخ الانسان او
في جلده ده هيمشي في الدم النهارده الابدي
ايه هيئه الدواء الامريكيه اللي هي اكثر
هيئات الدواء في العالم تحفظا
المفروض يعني
طبيه باستخدام النانو تكنولوجي الكترونيك
فمثلا غير موضوع الحبوب الذكيه دي
بداوا يصنعوا مايكروفايبرز هدوم تكون ذكيه
لنقل
[موسيقى]
القياسات الحيويه للجسد بالزبط يعني
دلوقتي سهل جدا ان انا لو عملت صوره للجلد
اعرف مثلا مقياس السكر الضغط الكلام ده
خلاص يعني بس انت بتقول فايبر يعني
لابس بدلتي فالبدله نفسها هي بتلمس جلدي
وتقول انا حالتي الصحيه بالضبط فمن داخل
الجسم وخارجه زي ما حضرتك اشرت النهارده
دافع عن بعض البنوك بدات تعرضه بره انه
يتزرع لي مايكروسب وبالتالي بتاعي يبقى
تحت الجلد ما حدش يقدر يسرقوا خالص طيب
السؤال المهم التاني اللي لازم ان احنا
نتكلم عليه حد يقول لي طب انا بعد ما هحط
الحاجات دي جوه جسمي
في حاجتين مهمين طب اللي هيحطهم بعديه
بسنه هياخد تكنولوجي لجسمه احسن من هياخد
نسخه اكثر تطورا اغير في الحقيقه انه ده
جزء من الابحاث
ان انا بعمل
ابديت بنعمل
مخ موديل قديم وبالتالي في مخ ثاني هيبقى
اغلى
لازم ننزل من الانترنت الابديت لمخنا طبعا
زي ما قلت كثير جدا
انا ممكن اعدي على سوفت وير اقول له
برمجني بسرعه يعني لانه انا دايما حد ممكن
ياخد نسخه اصليه وحد ياخد نسخه كده مقلده
يا سيد بيه انا دائما هذه يعني عندما ادعى
للتحدث في هذا الموضوع بقول لم اكن اتخيل
في يوم ان اهم فيلم ساينكشن او خيال علمي
مصري هيكون فيلم اللمبي 8 جيجا اللمبي ده
اللمبي 8 جيجا عملوا له زراعه لمايكرويف
في دماغه عشان كان بينسى فيخزن كل قانون
العقوبات هو محامي فبقى كل القوانين عملوا
لها لود في دماغه بقى محامي ليس يضارعه
طب لان الموضوع شيك جدا وفي تفاصيل كثيره
انا بس خايف انه انا معظم المتابعين واللي
بيشوفونا خلفيتهم احسن مني بكثير بس انا
بفترض ان انا الاساس على اساس ان انا اجهل
الناس بهذه العفشه
اذا حضرتك بتقول انه
الدقائق اللي احنا تحدثنا فيها ان
التكنولوجيا موجوده بالفعل
وهي قائمه واستخدمت بالفعل وان فيها
تحديين منها التحدي الاولاني حضرتك بتقوله
هو تكنولوجيا زرع شرائح والشرائح ديت
عباره عن كمبيوتر صغير مش كده برضو جوه
الانسان له اهداف مختلفه اشهرها وابسطها
انه يخلي بعض الاورجنز او الاعضاء في
الجسم يمكن ان تعمل بعد ان بعد ان كانت
معطله ولها اهداف اخرى انه يقدر يتفاعل من
غير لمس فان يحرك سياره يحرك يعطي اوامر
لصاروخ وهكذا او انه يبقى بياناته الشخصيه
موجوده من غير كريد فانا بمجرد ما المساله
يقدر يفتح حساب البنكي او الاخره بتقول ان
الشرائح ديت قدامها تحدين منها ان هي زي
اي شريحه محتاجه تتطور ماذا عن هذا التحدي
هيعملوا فيه ايه
زي ما قلنا انه هيحصل تنزيل للابديتس
دلوقتي اللي بنشتغل عليها هو ازاي يحصل
تنزيق داونلود من الانترنت
ده هياخدنا لجزء مهم جدا بس قبل ما نقوله
هو لو ايه اللي هيحصل لما البشر تبقى
مكمله او
بهذا الشكل هيظهر مفهوم
ظهر في افلام الخيال العلمي منذ سنوات
اللي هو سايبر بورد اللي هو الهجين ما بين
الانسان والاله هو ما زال الانسان ولكن
الهانست
بتكنولوجيا هو ده اللي حضرتك يعني
ان الانسان يتحول يبقى مزيج من الانسان
والاله بالظبط قبل ان ينتقل الى الثوره
الصناعيه الخامسه اللي بتعايش فيها
الانسان والاله بالظبط السؤال بتاع حضرتك
طيب لما احنا هنعمل ابديتس و داونلود
للابديت من الانترنت زي مثلا عشان نبسطها
للساده المشاهدين
لما بنفتح الموبايل يقول فيه ابديت جديد
فبينزل ابديت تفتح
مفهوم ممكن
فيقول لحضرتك في ابديت جديد فبنزل الابديت
نفس الكلام هنا بس ده هياخدنا لنقطه مهمه
جدا ده معناه ان هذه الشيبس ستكون متصله
بالانترنت بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر شكل
مباشر يعني على طول او من خلال الفون مثلا
التليفون المتصل بهذه التشيب طبعا وهو
اللي بينزل الابديتس وبعدين يبعتها لك
دايما متصل به او التلفزيون الذكي دائما
متصل بالانترنت وبينزل تحديثاته من خلال
الانترنت وده في الحقيقه فتح علم جديد مش
الانترنت
لا الانترنت
يعني بدل الايو تي بقى فيه اي او ام تي
بدل الانترنت الاشياء بقى انترنت الاشياء
الطبيه يعني بالضبط تمام انترنت الاشياء
الطبيه ده علم بدا يتفتح وبدات العالم
يشتغل عليه بشكل كبير في هذا الاتجاه كل
هذه التفاصيل اهم نقطه فيها انها في الاخر
انترنت الاشياء الطبيه وبالتالي كل ده في
الاخر متصل بالانترنت زي ما قلنا بشكل
مباشر او غير مباشر هذا يعني ان كل هذه
القياسات الحيويه وكل هذه البيانات وكل
هذه التعليمات لان الكاميرا بتبعت للشاب
والشبكه بتقول للمخ اذا في
عمليه
بيانات ثنائيه الاتجاه من والى المخ ما
الذي يضمن
وده على فكره مش بس القائمين بنظريه
المؤامره كل من يتحدثون في
امن المعلومات يجب ان يناقشوا ده ما الذي
يضمن اساءه
عدم اساءه استخدام ده
للتحكم في الجسم البشري والتحكم في جموع
البشر وما الذي يضمن انه اذا كان الشيبس
او الترانزستورز اصغر من الكورونا فيروس
ان يكون تم اطلاق شيبس في الفاكسينز بتاعه
الكورونا فيروس وكل هذه الامور
الاجابه
انه كل هذه البيانات
عاده
ما ينفعش انه
قدره التخزينيه تكون في مراكز بيانات
بسيطه دي لازم تتخزن فيما يسمى بالكلاود
او في الحوسبه السحابيه وفي الحوسبه
السحابيه هناك مفهومين مهم جدا بنفصل
بينهم
السكيورتي ان انا اضمن كمعد لهذه
التكنولوجي زي ايلون ماسك انه لا احد من
الهاكرز يخترق يخترق مستخدمي هذه
التكنولوجيا على غير تخطيط مني انا كمصنع
التكنولوجيا النقطه التانيه هي التراست او
الثقه كيف لي انا كاحمد بهاء او كسيد جبيل
ان اثق
نفسه لا يسيء استخدامها لنفسه او لجهات
اخرى بيتعاون معها تجاريه او غير تجاريه
هل تاذن لي اذا نسال السؤال بشكل ابسط
تتحرك اجبت تقريبا ولكن اسمح لي انا ان
ارابيك اسال السؤال واحصل على اجابه ابسط
من كده الان بما انه الاتجاه العلمي في
زرع شرائح الهدف منها يبدو نبيلا جدا ولا
اشكك في نبل الهدف على الاقل الان الان
العقل الانساني هيكون في شريحه والشريحه
دي ستقوم بوظائف اما في التحكم في الاشياء
عن بعد او في ان هي تشغل لي اعضاء في جسمي
كانت عاطله ما الذي يمنع ان يتم اختراقها
ويتم توجيهها من الجهه التي تقوم
بتشغيلها يعني ايوه انا فاهم ان حضرتك
بتتحدث عن مفهومين واستاذنك نتحدث عن
الفرق ما بين الامن والثقه في حلقه اخرى
دلوقتي انا بقى احنا في ملايين البشر
هفترض ان هم بداوا ملايين البشر ان لم يزد
ما الذي يضمن لي ان هناك شريحه الشريحه
ديت بتقول لي ان الشركات الكبيره اللي
منها شركه بتضمن لي انها توفر تكنولوجيا
يصعب العبث بها كلمه هفترض انه قادر على
ده ولو ان دايما في تكنولوجيا في دايما
قدره على اختراقها ما الذي يضمن ليا انا
اصلا الا يسيء زي ما حضرتك بتقول ان هو لا
يدري ويتحكم فيه القاعده الاولى يعني
الاجابه التفصيليه زي ما قلنا هتحتاج الى
حلقه اخرى ان شاء الله نتكلم فيها او
الفرق بين سكيورتي والتراست واللي بيضمن
الاتنين ولكن استطيع ان اجيب حضرتك في
جمله واحده يا ريت في القاعده الاولى في
علم تامين المعلومات بتقول انه
رونا نمبر وان
يعني في علم تامين المعلومات القاعده
الاولى ليس هناك نظام مؤمن ميه في الميه
من تامين المعلومات اذا لا يوجد ضمانات ما
يعني لا في ضمانات لا يوجد ضمانات كافيه
وفي ضمانات كافيه النهارده بتظهر زي ما
قلنا ده موضوع يحتاج الى حلقه متكامله
لكنه زي اي نظام
او نظام حرج
بيستخدم في العالم مدام في كمبيوتر وفي
انفورميشن وفي بيانات ومعلومات بيحدث
تراسلها وتبادلها ومعالجتها هناك بعض
المخاطره من ناحيه امن المعلومات ويبقى
صراع الخير والشر موجود كيف نحن من ذلك
وكيف يقوم المجرمين الرقميين بمحاوله
اختراق ذلك طيب انا هسال حضرتك سؤال اخير
اذا مع تطور هذه التكنولوجيا سوف يكون لها
اثار ايجابيه كثيره نامل فيها ان شاء الله
انه انسان مريض ما بيسمعش يقدروا يساعدوه
على السمع انسان لا يبصر يساعدوه على
الرؤيه او هكذا على الجانب السلبي يمكن ان
تكون المخاطر اللي اي حد هيتخوف منها انه
يحصل انه الابديت او التحديثات ليست كافيه
يحدث انه ممكن يتم تحديثها بما يريدون
يستطيع ان يوجهني ان افكر بالشكل الذي يرى
ده مش بعيد عن المنطق مش كده برضو نظريا
نظريا تبقى المساله متروكه لحسن نوايا من
يدير هذه الشركات
ولقضيه التران تحدثنا عنها مسبق من غير من
غير قضيه لاحقه يعني الترس هل نظريا ذلك
ممكن
ممكن ومن يتحدثون عن نظريه المؤامره زي ما
قلت بيتكلموا مثلا عن التحكم في جيوش بعد
كده
وتحركات الجنود بدل ما هم رايحين يحاربوا
العدو يحاربوا بعضهم طب وليه مؤامره انا
مش شايف فيها اصل كلمه نظريه المؤامره هي
المخاوف على شيء لا دليل عليه لكن انا
بتكلم على الخوف مشروعه انا اصبح عندي
شريحه الشريحه ديت قادره على التحكم في
اعضاء حيويه في جسمي وممكن تزيد مع الوقت
وكده كده في مهندس كمبيوتر قادر على
ادارتها ولا انا فاهم غلط
ايوه يعني عشان بس وقت الحلقه
نظريا ذلك ممكن ولكن هناك بعض الضمانات
لانه هذا الامر لا يتعلق فقط
بموضوع ده ده كل الانظمه الحرجه في العالم
بتعاني من هذه المشكله يعني مع اي طياره
موجوده في اي جيش في العالم ما هي في
الاخر فيها كمبيوتر ما الذي يضمن ان هذا
الكمبيوتر لا يتم اختراقه كل المعدات اللي
في الحروب الفرق الوحيد ان هي كانت معدات
احنا بنتكلم دلوقتي معده يمكن السيطره
عليها او اختراقها وتعطيلها او توجيهها او
حرفها عن مسارها ده قائم الان انا بتكلم
على مخ الانسان نفسه يعني في المثال اللي
حضرتك بتقول عليه وكان عندي ضيف تيار هنا
بيقول لي لما بتعطل اجهزه الكمبيوتر في
الطياره انا بخبرتك يا طيار باعوض الخلل
اللي في الاجهزه الالكترونيه الان هو مخه
هو نفسه اللي بيتم السيطره عليه
عشان كده هناك
مثلا يعني انا برده مش عايز اخش بهذا
الموضوع لانه كده ده موضوع كبير ولكن هناك
ضمانات جيده مش هقول
كامله
بتمكننا ان احنا ننتقل لانفسنا كمستخدمين
نروح مع انهي تقنيات وما نروحش مع انهي
تقنيات انا شاكر جدا معاه للدكتور حضرتك
برضو كالعاده يعني اجبت اسئله كثيره وطرحت
لنا الفكره بشكل جيد جدا
يعني اثرت في اذهاننا برضو مخاوف واسئله
اخرى انت حضرتك قلت نص جمله كده انه ممكن
جدا ان الدواء اللي انا باخده زي الفاكسين
ممكن يوضع فيه شرائح صغيره وان الشرائح في
نظريه مؤامره كامله انا ما بقولش ان فيه
ولكن القائلين بالنظريه المؤامره
بيتساءلوا ما الذي يضمن انا ما بقولش ان
هي موجوده او لا بس بتقول ان علم ممكن
يحدث ممكن انه ممكن
نتوقف علشان يعني لا نثقل على الناس بكمل
كبير من المعلومات
واستاذنك لوقتك سمح نستانف الحديث عن يعني
المستقبل بشكله المذهل الجديد علينا في
حلقات اخرى باذن الله بكل سرور يا فندم
ساعدت بحضرتك
وشكرا لحضراتكم قطعا بعض حضراتكم هيكون
عنده اسئله استاذنكم ابسط طريقه اكتبوها
وان شاء الله نطرحها على الدكتور احمد
بهاء في حلقات اخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى
اللقاء